right good humor a late start
this is usual on the emergency
evacuation announcement should be
required to evacuate building please
leave the building by the nearest
available exit the chamber or assembly
pointed in the public light off the side
of the silic suite please don't delay
the evacuation to collect any belongings
please don't return it to the building
the less you give them permission to do
so by counsel staff please also note the
meeting one be recorded titan-1
apologies for absence we have that's low
this is short
we've countless marine substituting
castle at Wilson we counselor mr. Foy
substituting counts the Steptoe with
councillor cut more substituting
counsellor away the counselor mrs.
Hughes substituting right non-members
attending minutes of the meeting found
on the 20th of July 2017 happy commuters
on noses aquarium accurate records that
meeting declarations of interest
for the sake of clarity bearing in mind
that the meeting is audio recorded and
the council itself has got a couple of
applications the declarations of
interests and things are a little bit
more complicated than normal but for the
sake of transparency I'm just going to
start with a short statement yes thank
you
1967
kappa xvii now through Rochefort members
of the government committee of being
asked to determine an application by
their own authority in relation to those
items the members interests
members of the Investment Board of
making decisions to progress projects as
part of the councilors policy to
maximize assets and your business plan
may be predisposed to consider an
application at the development committee
in a certain way
however those decisions do not take into
account aerial planning considerations
and they do not show a quick
determination on the part of those
members for those reasons these members
of the Investment Board who have
requested the dispensation have been
granted one by one journalist I would
invite investment board members to
disclose that they have another
if any member has not received about the
dispensation then I applied them to a
drill through chamber but these
particular items for members of the
project teams
you're almost further as you have
actively participated in progressing the
project to the development committee it
is the objective of the project team to
obtain approval of the application and
for that reason
no dispensation can be granted for those
members who have present see me I'd
invite you to declare and unlocking your
interest and withdrawal from the chamber
all these items you may be allowed to
listen to the officers presentation and
have five minutes to speak however if
you so wish to do so I should just add
that the same applies to visiting
members this evening as well thank you
that's the couple more Jim just
listening just to amazed I have applied
for and receive the appropriate
dispensation as a member of the
Investment Board skill
[Music]
and
[Music]
yes you have
[Music]
that's a new port it appears that you
might not even you haven't got the
dispensation in place and so devices
exist after presentations before the
discussion after presentations because
but
to do that now
I have some counsel standing could
substitute things have to do so now
there disappeared the duration anything
yes okay that's the Stanley you like to
write is everyone content with their
positions but they quietly appropriate
interest that the dispensations have
been gained by appropriate and the
progress is important these
technicalities are all regular right
okay and you're happy okay item six
council offices south street Rochford
have a presentation seventeenth ostrich
is equated to the city centre and
concession area white instead on the
agenda is the tundra this is 50%
application the building has been used
as office spaces of course until enforce
basically the systematic square meters
the proposal is we take existing this
must be one offices as required not a
very edgy news just into some measure
just proposed issues would be answered
when it ready
given the tongue sensor location which
is necessary especially officers
consider that maybe the building to the
recommendations there's a signature
there just reminder that we're not
actually approving were recommending
advising the Secretary of State that
were minded to approve is the
recommendation just right we're just
going to do
and yes in April before you may have to
you want to come in to say the start of
seven which would be the same as that
you've just all right the only members
wish to speak on this one it's the
staring thank you cheering I mean our
first report in this report
I think the difference I mean look it
was nice and three heritage especially
we see if the heritage assessment I'm
only like the previous experience where
we have similar issuing invitingly
rent reports and well because they were
ancient wars involved whatsoever to
space
with a microphone update so anything
that was brief and how it is taking
application for yourself the monitor for
one but as the good is not going to make
any alterations okay members are you
happy to advise the Secretary of State
that we are minded to approve listed
building consent subjects and conditions
condition points printed on six point
four on the change views and changing us
now item 7 is essentially the same but
is there anything else offices with
lights right application for this
utility descent must be assessed on how
the proposal impacts on the counter and
appearance of the parent leadership
because simply whether to grant this to
put an assent for any worse the LPO a
shallow cut special regards the
desirability of Pacific
many features of social architecture
Computer Services divided tasks person
not make any physical changes stability
which is that with the practice searches
of multitude recommendations therefore
[Music]
so this is advising the reminder to
approve the list again you can send
details of the same
[Music]
there's no works the are children
yourself some of our conditions
Priceline it doesn't apply remembers
we're happy to move to agreed
recommendation 3 okay to be called in
yes around 20 thank you item eight is
eight Paradise Falls well this is one
that might normally be delegated but
it's come to Connecticut as the
applications related to a member of
staff please it's very court
determination muslin an application
without doing it loses play house this
application necessary reading delicately
application pocket of the Senate has
played in the most essential and
important one of the focuses title eyes
by mr. Hauser disaster
to catch the sentox properties remember
these doctors phlogiston
went and ran that's the copy that
this is a page of the application site
2006 five persons wanted for Groupon
treasures of the drone this equated to
pair of cannibalism and the police the
proposal it's too late but some others
with a small flat with heavy loads this
is a each other similar to bones in park
lands as well which says any family
found that between the two game
employers that is why it's proponent of
this application supplementary document
c1 how to decide cease to secure fish
McLaughlin Thomas attain the
satisfactory provincial flags so it's
not an activity and activities
however it's some areas about lived or
miss full body character of the area in
this case so a woman even above aloof
endurance in her class have been
regulars as addressed by the previous
picture then for the view of this it is
considered that the proposal of existing
doors would not have ended to impact the
visual and digital character of the area
the officers know finishes that approval
numbers on page eight one say there's a
recommendation for durable
the property that we just looked at
comes home second relation to the one
we're looking at then please is it Nixle
there was a property in the close
vicinity just that our bill is straight
the principle of what's been proposed
here so it's not the same right no and
what is the distance between the two
dollars that you that is being proposed
as to what the money we won't have a
dark mansion on the park gardens it's
just a photographic illustration this
one talks about a meter off
we don't have the ability to scale on
that but just meet repentance then okay
what quite large there chin it is when
you when you look at Park Gardens if
you're making that proposal or Park or
how God sees a lot closer than what what
you immediately bit
okay I'll get to that monster any other
members wish to go and what
recommendation to approve is printed on
a printer with the perfect conditions
those ones in fact they're the approvals
we go to go again talking is past
item my little third item there is an
agenda for this one does any member not
see the addendum the exact continues
Express on this one this is very bozo
and Ricky's roving rora mr. strengths is
going to present on this one
Thank You chairman this application is
located on the north side of the beach
is broked here it just leads to the
settlement battements bridge which was
features for the edge of the image
houses like is this area roughly and
then we have a location and show more
specific for members but in total some
seven hectares in this vicinity and why
we're on this image and I've been mister
bear in mind that it's a mixture if you
like grasp and raising land grubby
really comes into the presentation later
on as we speak if we could just show the
location please drop just to see so the
members and see the extent at the
society if you've got the the council's
image where the sites shown in bold or
we look at that one place rain not fail
it's just worth noting members that the
extent of the site I said one that's the
lovely just moving up the page a bit
that might help a little as a great stop
the site does you see frontage to be
Chesebrough it runs in alongside a tree
nursery that's in this apartment
it turns behind that runs on a shorter
side down to the river then round as you
can see the straight line like that and
this this survey-based usefully tries
medallion a
there's a sort of recovery or the shrub
cover here as opposed to the open
grassland on the other side the proposal
is associated with an existing use for
agriculture that is the sort of grazing
in the green on and livestock in this
case mostly goats because see from the
officer report that is other livestock
there including their turkeys in the
hope of some cattle if we can see the
innovations please
the proposal is partly retrospective and
it's four to two buildings I'll actually
show you the layouts of those in a
minute
but it's simple agricultural buildings
you'll see 8 metres wide by 20 metres
deep it's retrospective as much as that
build one units which is the one they
would house the the vice document is two
units proposed the second variation of
the two buildings has opened scientists
and you can get feedstuffs in there and
equipment it's like a like a compliment
but the car prototype was closed on on
all sides with ones that you can get
easy access the other building that
you'll see is fully enclosed which is
where the livestock we're going for
overwintering and I mean a young etc if
we can just have a look at the site
layout and just the show members the
orientation of where the buildings are
on the site there's an access that's
proposed in this proposal comes down to
where the buildings are located in grub
area and those part of the application
as well - partly constructed with tree
planting other side and see it in
photographs that in a minute the
building that is retrospective is this
one the two buildings of the same
footprint and appearance that one is the
ones being constructed but there's a
second similar almost identical looking
building that the storage shed one I
showed you that has not been constructed
that he's there so this applications for
two buildings one of which has already
been constructed and the access rather
than going to
area further down if we could see the
entrance detail please Rob the
application shows an entrance formed on
two beaches Road here we are you come in
with recessed gates - to the road the
right of the carriageway is here the
sandblaster than existing edging on the
front recess some centimeters as you're
seen they know so the wider area for
parking and maneuvering as they open the
shut the gates or two vehicles could
stand drop into a single carriageway
that runs to the back of the site that
we saw on a smaller scale plan use just
see the gate photograph please just for
completeness these gates also have been
erected as part of the retrospective
aspects you can go to the first
photograph 11 please there was we once
inside the site they'll see that there's
a long track that this'll do it's in the
site and it journeys down to where we're
looking towards the other side of the
river crouch chance or Chum suicide and
the riverine beyond this area here
you'll see as you go down the grazed
areas you come to this rub area where
the building was it to be located if we
could see the existing goat house if you
can on Thursday stop there that's all
right that's okay that's the building
that's retrospective where the goats are
kept and you can see typical
agricultural building green cladding
corrugated profiles of interest is the
height which is agricultural buildings
go these days is quite shallow nor do
you see things much higher for the
tipping of machinery and storage of
aspect straw etc mechanically this is
only four point two meters or so which
is comparable to the heights of the
seawall which is just beyond forming a
backdrop to this elevation if you can
see the scrub photos rod which is 16
this gives members a better idea down
near the seawall again when the height
and described you see is typically about
ten feet three meters or so in height
sporadically about what about the site
now site is located in the greenberg we
can go back to the layout and please
rock but also the coastal protection
belt now in the green belt the
agricultural use is generally
permissible it's one of the few
exceptions that the government allows
planning authorities to accept if you
find a layer please Rob yeah okay and
the council's policies generally support
agricultural businesses and their
diversification so there is no issue
with this type of building as officers
can see Greenbelt zones it's typical
you've seen the designs that we usually
find and they're well colored in terms
of the backdrop and the area generally
but the site is also living the coastal
protection bill now that policies is
many years old and I think had it's at
its infancy and a lot of development
that have occurred along the coastline
things like jetties and water
recreational stuff whether it's
industrial stuff on the riverbanks
meeting
coastal locations as well as other
industrial developments as well now the
coastal protection of policy recognizes
the importance of the coastline both as
a recreation of assets is one of the
disturb their sales as well as the
importance or ecology such as the issues
of the migratory birds in the attempt to
approach
and Crouch histories primarily the
concern is is to make sure that the
characteristic that the landscape is
protected and enhanced now it's obvious
is considerably animal grazing on this
site which is a predominant use although
the building's support they primarily
keep the land open in Greenbelt terms
and the use of the land for agriculture
largely keeps the landscape of them as
it is it's just that in order to do that
the certain ansari buildings that are
support that used to allow it to to
continue so when you look at the policy
that we have it says that protect the
landscape and although these are new
buildings in that landscape given the
coloring and reciting against the
seawall amongst the scrub we've got not
a natural cover there that helps to
mitigate impacts are there an officer's
feel that as far as the customer
protection bill goes there's no strong
conflict with that and therefore the
recommendation is receiving the reports
is one of approval the addendum you'll
see that there is comments from the
parish council amongst other things they
raised the issue about the enforcement
post which came about in the direction
make sure but there is a caravan site in
this facility somewhere which is not be
parked in this application so the
enforcement case is ongoing but whilst
those investigations have been taken to
place the applicants taking the
initiative to make these submissions for
the agricultural works which is just
before you now so there may be some
other things you're aware of on the site
but I just asked members that this
application is about what you see before
you the access road and the two
buildings you're also seeing members
that Essex County London water
management team and we consult these
days on flood risk issues they have no
objections to raise against the
application so chairman the
recommendation of the yeah let's speak
on this once okay Kenny doctor yeah five
minutes I'll let you know when you've
got a minute to go
Thank You chairman and I think he
restricted her a very good summary of
the application and as the italic ation
is retrospective in part Essex copes
first moved to the site in spring of
2016 and purchased the goats in the
summer last year the business invested
over $70,000 fencing an infrastructure
to this site to establish their small
home in business with regard to the
development of site the business first
sought pre-application advice from
watcher council early last year and a
formal application for premium
application advice was submitted in
November the site visit wasn't taken
some informal advice given but no formal
written report the client proceeded with
what he thought on the informal advice
given was committed development under
the agriculture mentor developer rights
to proceed with one of the buildings
because his goats were in kid and they
needed shelter protection an initial
application was submitted to the council
in March it was rejected and resubmitted
in May and this is the application that
you have
it's acknowledged that they reckon the
recommendation from our planning offices
is for approval and we considered that
this proposal for agricultural element
is compliant with both national and
local planning policy the concerns of
the parish councillor noted my thoughts
are answers some of those concerns here
Essex goats are an established
agricultural business the holding at
rainbows end has a registered CPH of
holding number and a single single
business identifier from Defra the
business is also registered as a
livestock people with the aim to hae an
apartment health agency and a relevant
herd number applied to the goats the
business is a member of the British
throne society and the member of the
British royal goat society it's
knowledge that the building is within
the green belt and the coastal
protection area which is why the
buildings have been kept to a low height
as mr. strikes has already explained and
the scroll on site does shield these
buildings the sighting was particularly
chosen to maximize that the mitigation
that the scrub on site already provides
the flood risk has been assessed this is
a less vulnerable use within the flood
zone and there were no objections in
respect to flooding
historically there has been no record of
flooding in this area on this particular
land and in 2016 one of the wettest
recent years this land was not on the
water as mr. strikes have said a caravan
was brought onto site recently during
the kidding season when the Lambs with
them the lambs the goats were kidding an
on-site supervision was needed this
temporary siting is permissible under
part 5 class and the general critter
development order an application to
regularize a longer-term siting of the
caravan is due to be submitted to
watchmen as agreed with the council's
enforcement team that we're talking to
this issue in Adam mr. strikes have said
it's an entirely separate from the
development under consider
this application we're seeking to
consolidate small agricultural small
holding on this site it's entirely
appropriate development in the green
belt and I would kindly ask councillors
to support this proposal thank you
Castle black
I purpose it is interesting it with our
sweetie fabric which opened up with an
image from Google back to the rather
funny green looking area by the river
and it all look the same at this time
the areas look very similar I will at
least certainly were feeding lovely
agent but this is a perfectly acceptable
use them to improve their jobs exactly
comfortable that's what green box for
many cases if it's green belt I hope you
know is tonight my concerns about
whether it does violate the coastal
protection girl policies accessibility
step back - - is very similar to these
self amperage slightly we looked at last
time the parish council are concerned I
think about development going on from
here as well could be like Enterprise
you've got goats you've got turkeys
coming out I imagine turkeys within
supervisory duties over the caravan
their expectation of the site wow so
many it's a question of did we I think
this above you promised except to point
on but I would say those businesses are
very close to the river where was the
percentage that last one was quite than
the way from the liver but the belt was
very bright
and I'm not inclined to support it thank
you I'll switch to speak on this one
okay members we've had snow from Castle
black
we've got on nine point one point for an
approval recommendation with some
conditions so I asked those members in
favor of the approval to please indicate
that was a game
thank you that's also a Sapru and that
takes us to the end of one of the
quickest funny making me quite a while
thank you very much for your attendance
you